so we've got sharpie gate which we'll
follow up on a little bit later it now
appears that it wasn't merely that
Donald Trump held up a Sharpie modified
hurricane map we're now getting reports
from White House insiders that Donald
Trump personally sharp heed the
hurricane map itself there's one problem
with that claim and I'll talk about it
later in the show but before we even get
to that Donald Trump had a completely
separate and crazed and erratic fit on
Twitter over the weekend starting about
Barack Obama
now remember when Barack Obama was
president I know many of you do
Republicans wouldn't stop saying hey
Democrats george w bush isn't president
anymore
don't mention george w bush just talk
about Barack Obama no more talk about
Bush I wish one of them would be
intellectually honest enough to give the
same advice to Donald Trump and
Republicans now Barack Obama's not
president anymore Hillary Clinton never
was president stop talking about both of
them but Donald Trump going off on
Twitter on Barack Obama shifting
directly from that Twitter tirade into
yes one related to Hurricane Dorian and
the map and fake news so disclaimer
before we get into this I've said before
many times we don't want to just cover
Trump tweets for the sake of covering
Trump tweets and we don't and in fact
today I'm going to skip over a ton of
them because they're not really related
it's theirs tweets that are differently
incoherent which are not particularly
relevant to the story we're talking
about today today I'm going to focus on
specifically Trump's tweets about Obama
and the Alabama stuff and fake news now
all of what I'm going to show you
happened basically within 24 hours not
even early this weekend so understand
this is sort of about the content of the
tweets but this is happening in one day
this is one day of some of Donald
Trump's tweets this is the president
look at the emotional instability look
at the amount of time that is being
spent tweeting falsehoods instead of
being President so let's just jump right
into it starting off with the
immigration stuff and Obama the
immigration law Institute's Christopher
Heydrich says the Supreme Court has to
look at whether daca is lawful what they
are looking at now is whether Trump's
rescission of daca is lawful must
consider lawfulness of daca itself look
very odd that President Trump doesn't
have the discretion to end the program
that President Obama began in his
discretion already I mean the language
is crazy it's all crazy that program was
unlawful to begin with I think it's very
unlikely that the Supreme Court is going
to issue an order reinstating what it
believes is an unlawful program daca is
unlawful
President Obama never had the legal
right to sign daca and he indicated so
at the time of signing but in any event
how can he have the right to sign and I
don't have the right to unsigned totally
illegal document which would actually
give the president new powers daca will
be going before the Supreme Court it is
a document that even President Obama
didn't feel he had the legal right to
sign he signed it anyway I mean this is
incoherent folks rest assured that if
the Supreme Court does would all say it
must based on the law a bipartisan deal
will be made the benefit of all so this
is the Obama daca aunt and it makes no
sense at all Obama didn't sign daca it
was a presidential memo to expand
something that already existed there are
more details but this is not a story
about immigration it is about the
unhinged and unstable nature of the
president so there are four tweets
they're just rants they mean nothing of
substance but his followers see that as
strong leadership believe it or not so
then a few hours go by and Donald Trump
tweets about the fed another popular
target going from slamming Obama to
slamming the Fed saying quote I agree
with Jim Cramer the Fed should lower
rates they were way too early to raise
and way too late to cut and big dose
quantitative tightening didn't exactly
help either where did I find this guy
Jerome oh well you can't win them all so
when he says where did I find this guy
Jerome he's talking about Fed chief
Jerome Powell who of course Trump picked
after bragging that one of the hallmarks
of his administration would be
appointing the best people if Jerome's
not great then it's on Trump now we're
up to five tweets then he tweets some
compliments about Fox News people Sarah
Huckabee Sanders newly a contributor
Jeanine Pirro I'm not even including
those then he goes back to the hurricane
and remember this is all the same day
quote the fake news media was fixated on
fact that I properly said at the
beginnings of Hurricane Dorian that in
addition to Florida and other states
Alabama may also be grazed or hit they
went capital C crazy hoping against hope
that I made a mistake which I didn't
check out Maps this nonsense has never
happened to another president because
other presidents aren't doing what
you're doing four days of corrupt
reporting still without an apology but
there are many things that the fake news
media has not apologized to me for like
the witch hunter Spygate the lamestream
media and their Democrat partner should
start playing it straight it would be so
much better for our country so we're now
up to eight tweets once again sort of
amalgamating the issues of so-called
fake news the hurricane dorian fiasco
making himself out to be the victim and
martyr and calling the russia probe a
hoax conspiracy this is still one day
friday then tweet 9 in this series is
trump again attacking the so-called fake
news quote the economy is great the only
thing adding to quote uncertainty is the
fake news that's tweet 9 and it's still
september 6th and i'm not including the
ones about puro and sanders and then he
goes into false statements about tariffs
quote china just enacted a major
stimulus plan with all the tariffs they
are paying to the USA billions and
billions of dollars they need it in the
meantime our Federal Reserve sits back
and does nothing now of course China
doesn't pay the tariffs American
companies buying Chinese stuff pay the
tariffs and then they pass on the cost
of those tariffs onto you and me
American consumers that's the tenth
tweet and these are just the policy ones
again he also spent half the day
tweeting compliments to a variety of Fox
News hosts stop talking about Obama stop
lying about how tariffs work stop lying
about investigative journalism being
fake news stop lying about Hurricane
Dorian Trump is trying to bully society
and the economy into some kind of stupid
submission by attacking media and using
Twitter and they're not fully submitting
to him some enclaves have submitted to
Trump that's sad that's disappointing if
we do not vote this out in November
of 2020 we deserve another four years of
this as a society now I know the people
who vote for someone else they don't
personally deserve it but if as a
country we cannot eradicate the type of
pseudo and anti intellectualism
and non thinking hyper partisan a
sticking like glue to this incompetent
man then as a society as a country we
ultimately will deserve another four
years of this which is what we might get
let me know what you think about all of
this are you just depressed
are you experiencing something else I'm
on Twitter at D Pakman the show is on
Twitter at David Pakman show hey this is
a funny one Fox News had a sort of town
hall with or an audience of law
enforcement and first responders and it
went horribly wrong when not a single
one of them maybe one person in the
audience was willing to validate the
entire war on cops narrative that Fox
News has been pushing for years this is
hilarious and when it happens it
actually happened during the Bernie
Sanders town hall on Fox News a few
months ago I'll tell you about that in a
second if you've forgotten about it
but first let's take a look at a clip
where Fox News tries to expose the
violent evil anti police leftists by
saying put your hands up if you've had
liquids thrown at you or been heckled or
disrespected or whatever and maybe one
hand goes up it might have been someone
just trying to say they needed to get up
to go to the bathroom truly truly
awkward take a look at this you know the
conversation in this country has really
changed you have lawmakers that are
going to restaurants they're harassed
with their families and they have to
think okay wife/husband how do we
prepare for this if we get into the
situation you have firefighters you have
police officers on the street they have
to think what do we do when this happens
how did we get to that place look at
that look at that post New York Post
says how dare you calling these men and
these women that are doing this throwing
water throwing no matter how high when
President Trump stands up and says I'm
for the taxpayers and the citizens and
the people who came here legally right
it resonates so much with people because
you see another side of the aisle an
entire party saying we're the party of
illegality we're the party of non
citizenship and he says now once
last time I checked America still
matters all right can we see the hands
of the people here today the first
responders in law enforcement who have
encountered anything like that in the
last year or so in New York or wherever
you are with water hit with milk
disrespected taunted know anyone that
has well that's good all right well
let's talk let's talk a little bit about
just generally who would like to talk on
TV right now I would imagine everybody
another swing and a Miss again there was
one guy sort of in the back row who kind
of seemed like he was raising a finger I
don't know if he was just getting a fly
away from him but again the narrative
failing and this is one of those tired
old narratives that the right-wing media
tries to push in reaction to stories
about police killing unarmed black teens
and black men the real war is against
police and the real problem they want us
to believe is that the left hates public
servants and law enforcement the truth
is let's just step aside from the
partisanship we have a country of three
hundred and forty million people we can
find anecdotal examples of everything
you can at the same time have examples
of police behaving badly who should be
held to account for it but mostly police
departments made up of good people
trying to do the right thing and I think
that that's what we have you can at the
same time have examples of anti feh or
whoever treating law enforcement poorly
and attacking them and they should be
held to account but mostly we have a
population that by and large respects
police and treats them well this is not
shocking and there was a very similar
backfire when Fox News anchors during
the Bernie Sanders Fox News Town Hall
they asked the room who would really
give up their for-profit employer linked
health insurance for a government
program no one would do that right and
basically the entire rooms hands went up
and they cheered remember this I want to
ask the audience a question if you could
raise your hand here a show of hands of
how many people get their insurance from
work private insurance right now how
many get it from private insurance okay
now of those how many are willing to
transition to what the senator says a
government runs
whoa whoa we can't be having that
another one of these hilarious backfires
that just it allows the tiniest bit of
reality into the prevailing foxnews
narrative and it can convince a few
people now if you really want to see a
tax on first responders to go back to
what Fox News is talking about if you
want to see a tax on the military on
public servants and government employees
look at the Oval Office look no further
than Donald Trump I cannot think of any
president that has gone after the FBI
prisoners of war Gold Star families
intelligence analysts diplomats public
servants more than Donald Trump has it's
another example of projection plain and
simple and isn't it delightful to see it
backfire in the faces of Fox news
anchors that we have come to a see try
this stuff again and again and again
over the years I think it's a great to
see and it does hopefully help to Pierce
at least a few people's echo chambers
and filter bubbles make sure you're
following the David Pakman show on
instagram at david pakman show while you
are there follow me on instagram at
david pakman updates from my garden
coming up later today possibly breaking
news contained there for sure so I'm
going to have some sort of wrap up in
highlights of this extremely erratic
behavior from our president over the
weekend this includes continuing the
farce that is sharpy gate this includes
authoritarian demands that Noah not
contradict NOAA that is NOAA not
contradict his claims about Hurricane
Dorian putting Alabama at risk but
before we even get to that because I do
want to run through some of those
stories a little bit we're now learning
and it makes sense that Donald Trump's
own advisors the brown-nosing sycophants
who will stand behind the guy until the
most extenuating and absurd
circumstances make it all but impossible
to defend him even Trump's own advisors
are starting to privately say that
they're worried about Donald Trump's
mental state after this last week of
just outrageously erratic and volatile
behavior so
we see the public part the unhinged
tweet storms the confused slow speeches
while he seems to be gripping the POE to
the electors and wrestling with his own
tongue the angry speeches but that's
just the public side and there's the
behind the scenes which is an entire
other situation going on privately which
Donald Trump's aides are now coming
clean about Trump's aides and confidants
are now telling business insider that he
is experiencing bipolar mood changes and
I don't mean bipolar in the psychiatric
sense I mean bipolar in terms of up and
down up and down mood changes from one
minute to the next
based sometimes merely on seeing a news
headline that he doesn't like this guy
is so trigger Abul and so volatile that
sometimes according to his own aides and
advisers his entire schedule will be
changed because he sees some negative
story about him which sends him into a
complete and total tailspin such that
he's unable to do or unwilling to do
anything for the rest of the day quote
from one Republican strategist who is
frequently in contact with the White
House he's deteriorating in plain sight
we see it publicly right just by itself
what we see publicly would be enough to
confirm that this is someone who is
temper mentally unfit to be President of
the United States and aides are saying
that the public component is nothing
compared to the private component a
person whose clothes who was close to
Donald Trump's legal team during the
Russia investigation told a business
insider that Trump's public statements
were quote nothing compared to what he's
like behind closed doors the Alabama
thing which we've been in because we'll
continue talking about a little bit is
particularly worrying to them because it
could have all been prevented by saying
oh I mentioned Alabama could have been
hit by the hurricane
turns out hurricane durian wasn't
heading there we should all be glad
about that
that people in Alabama weren't in harm's
way we're gonna work on helping the
people who were in harm's way instead it
has been this endless never-ending lies
and cover-ups including drawing on a
hurricane map with a sharpie which we
talked about last week so this is no
longer about Donald Trump lying
Trump's aides and confidants are saying
everyone is used to the lies already sad
that we've become completely accustomed
to that but that this Alabama thing has
crossed over to another level altogether
that is to to them to quote them quote a
deterioration in plain sight 15 tweets
and 5 maps about the Alabama hurricane
fiasco and this is unfortunately and I
mean that it's not a surprise to anyone
who's been watching or listening to my
program and paying attention to this
he's been getting worse and worse and
worse for years now and he controls
nuclear weapons and geopolitics and our
relationships to every historical world
a lie of importance to the United States
if he merely stays on the same
trajectory like nothing gets worse
nothing accelerates he just stays on the
same decline trajectory between now and
Election Day
imagine what we will be dealing with by
November of 2020 especially if his
polling numbers don't improve and an
even more deteriorated Donald Trump
believes that he's likely to lose in
November of 2020 this will become the
stuff of nightmares and just imagine if
he starts to think that as a result of
losing in November of 2020 he might end
up indicted it will be more outrageous
than we can likely imagine he will be
desperate to prove non-existent voter
fraud he will be desperate to avoid the
possibility of indictment and maybe just
as importantly for him global
embarrassment as a result of that
indictment there's actually an
interesting split kind of developing in
the Trump supporter camp although they
all are still likely to vote for him in
2020 you've got on one side the trumpets
who are sort of doubling down and
they're pretending that everything
Trump's doing is normal that any
critique of Trump is merely fake news
meant to take down a president who won't
stop winning that's the DoubleDown
trumpets but you've got this other wing
of Trump is developing there the
trumpets who realize they made a mistake
in supporting this existential threat to
humanity and they have just stopped
paying attention to Donald Trump and use
headlines they're sort of pretending
that the president what oh I you know I
just work I
live my life I haven't heard of any of
it they're sort of struggling to remain
ignorant deliberately and uninformed for
their own benefit and to placate their
cognitive dissonance those are the two
sides unlikely either side is ultimately
going to vote for a Democrat but we'll
talk about that and now let's get into
the specifics of the insanity that this
weekend saw you know how the right loves
to talk about triggering the Liberals
owning the libs and it's all extremely
childish and unproductive when it comes
to furthering political discourse I
agree with all that and yet I still find
it endlessly entertaining Stussy Donald
Trump so easily triggered by reality
including the reality of his terrible
and diving opinion polls and his
plummeting approval rating so let me set
this up for you so that we're all on the
same page presidential approval
presidential approval absent flows it
rises and falls and very often it will
find kind of a relatively predictable
range over longer periods of time like a
year or a presidential term except when
really out of the ordinary things happen
so like 9/11 under george w bush was one
of those extraordinary and and unique
things that can shift presidential
approval outside of its normal range so
ABC Washington Post recently released a
joint poll on approval rating for Trump
and it once again shows that recently
Donald Trump's approval is falling
people really think the guy is genuinely
doing a bad job in a number of specific
areas including the economy trade and so
on and Donald Trump erupts on Twitter
yesterday and today claiming that this
is something even that lawyers maybe
should be involved in because it's
another one of these fake polls that
Donald Trump gets extraordinarily
conspiratorial about and goes into these
unhinged tweet rants where he seems to
be completely disconnected disconnected
that is from how polls actually work
here is Donald Trump tweeting yesterday
quote ABC Washington Post poll was the
worst and most inaccurate
Paul of any taken prior to the 2016
election when my lawyers protested they
took a 12-point down and brought it to
almost even by Election Day it was a
fake poll by two very bad and dangerous
media outlets sad these complaints are
so flaccid so feeble so puny and fragile
that only the most uninformed and
intellectually insignificant followers
could possibly fall for this stuff the
polls are fake this is the most
inaccurate poll everything is always
completely hyperbolic and unbelievable
from this guy and the truth is there's
nothing controversial about this ABC
Washington Post poll it shows the same
thing that most serious polls show it
shows that Donald Trump's high approval
during his term was about 44% pretty
normal for an unpopular incompetent
president in our hyper partisan
environment and on the downside the
Donald Trump approval rating sort of has
bottomed out at around 37 38 % and
that's where it is right now it has
steadily dropped over the last several
months to 38% this is not a rare or
unusual low point for a totally
incompetent president in once again a
hyper partisan environment where
something like 20% of the population
will always say they support the
president you've got another 815 who
will be sort of on and off about
approving of the president and there's
just nothing remotely hard or difficult
to believe about this Trump ranges from
about 36 37 to 43 44 in all serious
polls lately there are recession fears
there's the China tariff stuff there's
the Alabama Sharpie Fiasco which is just
embarrassing so Donald Trump's
embarrassments continue and polling is a
little bit lower what is there even to
disagree with here and then Donald Trump
this morning continuing the onslaught of
just erratic tweets a brutal assault on
the English language that that Donald
Trump has been participating in four
years now saying quote in a hypothetical
poll done by one of the worst pollsters
of them all the Amazon Washington Post a
see which predicted I with who's too
crooked Hillary by 15 points how did
that work out
sleepy Joe Pocahontas and virtually all
others it's so hard to take this
seriously would beat me in the general
election this is a phony suppression
poll meant to build up their Democrat
partners I haven't even started
campaigning yet and I'm constantly
fighting fake news like Russia Russia
Russia look at North Carolina last night
Dan Bishop down big in the polls wins
easier than 2016 Donald Trump would be
more popular if he just got off Twitter
and was less visible it's sort of like
the referees in sporting events if
you're talking about the referees that's
probably a sign that the referees are
causing problems for themselves in the
same way if you don't notice the
referees you probably default to their
doing an okay job officiating this game
in the same way if you're aware of
Donald Trump erratically tweeting about
this that and the other thing all the
time it's not helping Trump and when you
look at the Russia probe if Trump had
just stayed silent on Russia not tweeted
about it not attempted attempted to
obstruct all the time it would have gone
much better for him so here's my
question to you am i immature for
finding Donald Trump being so easily
triggered to be hilarious
I'm a regular critic of the way in which
political discourse has devolved in
course and I want depth I want to talk
issues I want to deep propagandize media
I mean all of it but at the same time
when I see Trump triggered so easily
daily like the guy has the thinnest skin
I find it hilarious ly entertaining tell
me if I'm a bad person because of that
tell me if I'm immature I want to hear
from you I'm on Twitter at D Pakman the
show is on twitter at david pakman show
and the david pakman show is also now on
twitch at twitch.tv slash david pakman
make sure if you have an Amazon Prime
subscription to subscribe with twitch
prime to twitch.tv slash david pakman it
costs you nothing but it supports our
show and that's where I will be
streaming commentary live tomorrow
evening of the 3rd 2020 Democratic
primary present
she'll debate we will see you then and
also back in a couple of minutes with
much more to discuss today so at first
when Fox News host Shepard Smith would
criticize Trump here or there call out
some obvious Trump lie it was sort of a
curiosity and it's now happening in such
a way that I'm increasingly convinced
that this is actually part of a crafted
strategy around Shepard Smith I've got a
clip for you here where Shep Smith
straight up calls Donald Trump's
hurricane hurricane durian Sharpie
Fiasco fake news to find and we have to
really understand this for what it is
but first let's look at the clip
remember this is on right-wing Fox News
some things in Trump plan dia are
inexplicable this week's edition the
president's ongoing claim that Alabama
was at risk from Hurricane Dorian it
wasn't maybe he got some bad info from
somebody maybe he made a mistake maybe
he was confused we don't know but he was
wrong and since for days and days he's
been insisting with fake visual aids in
hand that he was right and then calling
it what it is fake news defined why
would the President of the United States
do this he D cries fake news that isn't
and disseminates fake news that is think
China pays the tariffs the wall is going
up historic inauguration crowds Russia
probe is a witch-hunt you need an ID to
buy cereal noise from windmills causes
cancer it's endless and now the Sharpie
map that hurricanes Alabama a reporter
asked him about it he doesn't know but
he won't let it go yesterday he brought
out another map and a statement that
reads this was the originally projected
path of the hurricane in its early
stages as you can see almost all models
predicted it would go through Florida
and hitting Georgia and Alabama I accept
the fake news apologies this is where it
one where he can apologize and just move
on that map was from the day hurricane
but came a hurricane eight days ago
August the 28th it was four days old at
the precise time he said Alabama would
likely be hit harder than anticipated
and by then
it was fake news defined on a very
serious subject this is not Shep Smith
stepping out of line with a disdain
against his bosses at Fox News it's
abundantly clear that this is happening
with Fox News's executives approving at
least implicitly and I've been telling
you this for nearly two years at this
point I get emails from people how is
Shep getting away with this isn't Shep
potentially going to get fired we need
to reset our analysis of how corporate
media works Fox News wants to make money
above all else they've decided to do
this with right-wing editorial positions
in general they're not married to Trump
but they are right-wing but they also
benefit from having some ideological
cover especially when it seems that they
may break with the Trump train so what
you need to understand is that Shep
Smith provides ideological cover to Fox
News with safe calculated descent from
the everything Trump says his gospel
perspective which you see with Sean
Hannity and Jeanine Pirro and Laura
Ingraham and many others Shep Smith
isn't going to do anything that would
really damage Fox News like for example
Shep's not going to call out the lack of
regulation that allows corporate media
outlets to become so big and
monopolistic and be so intertwined with
government and Internet service
providers and ultimately foment
narratives that don't challenge their
privileged status as legacy elite
corporate media he's never gonna do that
Trump will tell a thousand lies and
every once in a while Shep will call one
or two of them out for being lies it
will get some people on the left to
reconsider whether Fox News is as bad as
we think it is
it'll get some discussion about what's
going on on Fox News it will get some
right-wingers saying homophobic things
about Shepard Smith and calling for his
firing yes but the biggest thing that
this does is create some deniability for
Fox News to say look we don't always
carry water for Trump we don't always
defend everything a Republican does so
our analysis must account for the
endgame in the short run at the
micro-level
it's good to expose some trumpets
watching Fox to a tiny dose of reality
in the big picture
Shep Smith on Fox News occasionally
telling some uncontroversial truth on
controversial to us that is is not going
to change the role that FoxNews in the
corporate media space plays and that's
the analysis that I've been making for a
long time to the extent that someone's
echo chamber might be pierced by Shep
great maybe it'll bring a little small
electoral advantage in 2020 if enough
trumpets have their echo chamber pierced
by Shep Smith but it does nothing to
achieve the wholesale reform goals and D
corporatization and D propagandas ation
of corporate profit driven media that
we've been talking about and it's really
important merely to acknowledge what's
happening with Shep for what it is and
not go beyond that because it simply
doesn't make sense and it's not actually
borne out by the facts as many of you
know I like Bernie Sanders a lot I think
he has great policies he's one of the
most progressive candidates running
along with Elizabeth Warren I'd be
thrilled for Bernie Sanders to be the
Democratic nominee and take on Donald
Trump but when people I like do
something I disagree with I say it and
Bernie Sanders has made a major mistake
in naming a woman named Linda Sarsour as
a campaign surrogate now I know I'm
going to get crushed for this by a
sliver of the left people may cancel
paid memberships they'll be angry that I
have the audacity to call out a woman
who happens to be Muslim an identity
politics argument but I am making the
effort not to self-censor and I just see
this as a mistake Linda Sarsour is from
the toxic wing of the American left she
is someone who has played coy with and
refused to denounce anti-semitic Nation
of Islam leader Louis Farrakhan she is
someone who has participated in
marginalizing Jewish women in her role
as founder of the women's March which
I've previously talked about
I don't believe Bernie Sanders should
have anything to do with Linda Sarsour
this is simply a mistake plain and
simple the Bernie campaign over the
weekend tweeted a video of Linda Sarsour
speaking where she is identified merely
as a civil rights activist and 2020
surrogate of Bernie Sanders
but the truth is that she has a very
very ugly past again Linda Sarsour is a
founder of the women's March she's one
of the three founders I've told you
about before
along with Tameka Mallory and Bob bland
who allowed anti-semitism to pervade the
movement who didn't consider Jewish
women important to the movement and
marginalized them who played coy Andrew
cozy with anti-semitic extremist Nation
of Islam leader Louis Farrakhan who I've
widely denounced before and it shouldn't
be difficult anyone who cares about
civil rights and non-discrimination and
inclusion no matter what your political
ideology is you should just denounce
Louis Farrakhan it shouldn't be
difficult and Bernie should have nothing
to do with this and in fact she has
blamed white women for the anti-abortion
heartbeat bill that Georgia tried to
pass she has defended Sharia law in a
series of tweets trying to put a
positive spin on it other left and
Democratic groups have figured this out
for example the DNC ended its support of
the women's March over exactly what I've
described to you before having people
like Linda Sarsour in the picture is
what hurts our own credibility I don't
care about Linda Sarsour personally this
is about what this does to the movement
to have people like this involved even
on the israeli-palestinian conflict it
quite frankly doesn't seem like Linda
Sarsour and Bernie Sanders are on the
same page Bernie has repeated many times
when Israel is attacked by rockets it
has a right to defend itself he makes
clear he's not going to play the
demonization games that lots of people
like Belinda Sarsour play we just don't
need them all of the productive views
that Linda Sarsour might hold are held
by plenty of people who aren't toxic and
who aren't associated with people like
Louis Farrakhan she wants Medicare for
all great so do I she wants to ition
free college and a $15 minimum wage lots
of people on the left do there's no
reason to make her a surrogate for
Bernie Sanders it's not my left I'm
actually surprised this is even
something that Bernie Sanders would
entertain given his track record he may
simply have no idea what's going on with
Linda Sarsour but
I would encourage the left not to dabble
with this toxic wing because there is
literally no upside there's no policy
upside there's no ideological upside
there's no public relations upside even
if you don't personally find Linda
Sarsour problematic even though I
believe that you should
there is no strategic argument to be
made for her involvement in Bernie
Sanders campaign period now if you
disagree with me let me know but try to
do it in a way that's respectful right
let's let's see if you can actually do
that because I know exactly what I'm
bracing for by even talking about this
make sure you're following the david
pakman show on instagram at david pakman
show while you're there follow me on
instagram at david pakman there is a
stunning new poll out of Texas which is
also sort of not stunning if you've been
paying attention for the last ten years
and what the poll tells us is that Texas
is no longer a safe trump state in 2020
this is extraordinary and the
implications are wide reaching there's a
new Univision poll which shows that 40%
of registered Texas voters now say they
will vote for the Democrat that
ultimately wins the primary instead of
Donald Trump only 33 percent say that
they will vote for Donald Trump in Texas
once you include undecideds who are
leaning one way or the other the
advantage definitely shrinks it becomes
Democrat 47 Trump 42 now that is only 89
percent total that still leaves 11
percent gray area but it doesn't matter
because these numbers are already even
accounting for that 11 percent that is a
fully undecided this is already a
massive change from years past this is
something we've been talking about for a
very long time Texas could become a
swing state a purple state and Donald
Trump might be accelerating that to
happen even sooner and a big part of
that as we've been following for years
will be the effect of Hispanic voters
who plan to vote for the Democrat
whoever it is over Donald Trump by a 69
to 19 margin in Texas that is a
the point margin to Donald Trump's
disadvantage among Hispanic voters in
Texas now let's be crystal clear this
does not mean I expect Donald Trump to
lose Texas in 2020 Republicans win Texas
often they've been winning it for a very
long time but if it's even remotely this
close it signals really bad things for
Donald Trump nationally in 2016 Donald
Trump won Texas over Hillary by nine
points okay
52 to 43 in 2012 even though Barack
Obama won hugely at the national level
being reelected of course Barack Obama
lost Texas to Mitt Romney 57 to 41 a 16
point deficit what that tells us is that
if it's even close in Texas if Trump
wins Texas but only by two three four
five it is really bad in terms of what
it signals for Donald Trump nationally
and this is actually Texas sandwiched in
a bigger story which is developing which
is that if we get the vote out and that
is a very big if there's a massive
opportunity to put in play states that
are not usually in play all those
possibly future purple states are
potentially winnable in 2020 Georgia
could be in play
Trump won Georgia in 2016 but he trails
a generic Democratic challenger there
according to a poll from eight weeks ago
North Carolina same thing Donald from
won it in 2016
Trump is losing by five points to an
as-yet unnamed generic future Democratic
nominee then you've got Pennsylvania
Wisconsin and Michigan which are always
in play for the Democratic candidate if
we actually go and try to win them the
polling even in Florida is not super
recent but Biden was plus three over
Trump Bernie was up a similar margin
over Trump the last time that poll was
done this is not a foregone conclusion
Trump could also win reelection but this
is just a matter of do we get the vote
out so when you hear me talk about this
please don't react by thinking oh we've
got everything we don't need to work we
don't need to vote we don't need to go
and get the vote out the reaction should
be Wow
Donald Trump is unpopular in many red
states if we
work incredibly hard if we mobilize
people who already don't like Trump and
agree with us on policy but often don't
vote if we mobilize them to go out and
vote then we have a shot at some of
these states and that should be the
attitude and this polling only supports
that view if we don't get the vote out
none of this stuff matters it becomes
completely academic and it becomes
another four years of Donald Trump
saying the polls said this before the
election and I won again I don't want
that to happen I know most people in the
audience don't want that to happen the
opportunity is there we've got to get
the vote out here's some genuinely
bizarre video of Donald Trump trying to
make a point I guess about why he's
taking vaping so seriously and he refers
to his own son I mean Barron Trump is
his own son at least as far as we know
as milania's son and there's really no
other way to introduce it other than
that this is following the trend of
Trump seeming to have no emotional
connection to his own children beyond
the fact that many times he said Ivanka
has just an amazing body we've heard
that from him before but other than that
it's hard to really see him say anything
that suggests an emotional connection to
his kids here's Trump I guess trying to
explain why vaping is something Melania
is interested in being involved in
listen to how he refers to his own kid
vaping has become a very big business as
I understand it like a giant business at
a very short period of time but we can't
allow people to get sick and we can't
have our youth be so affected and I'm
hearing it and that's how the first lady
got involved she's got a son together
that is a beautiful young man and she
feels very very strongly about it she's
seen it we're both reading it is this
the strangest way to refer to your own
kid does anybody that anybody has ever
heard Melania cares about vaping because
she has a son which is his son Barron
Trump she has a son and it has motivated
her to care about vaping someday maybe
Trump would get a chance to meet her son
it almost sounds like the next thing he
would say would be this is a guy who
either doesn't care about his son nor
Specht his wife or again I mean I I know
some people don't don't like this line
but is the experiencing such cognitive
decline that this is how he's now
referring to his own kids I've been I'm
not joking here I've been around people
with Alzheimer's and one of the things
that happens is they will get sometimes
confused there will be people that they
know are connected to them in some way
family members or significant others or
whatever the case may be
and they recognize that they know who
the person is there is a connection but
they refer to them in a way where
there's confusion about how the person
is connected to them they mentioned only
the connection to others as if they
remember the person and one connection
but not how they relate to that person
this is exactly what Trump seems to be
doing here now it may have nothing to do
with that this may merely be a
representation of how little Trump cares
about his own kid any normal person
who's either functioning normally
cognitively or is relating in a healthy
way to their wife and kid would say
something like we have a wonderful son
or something along those lines
it wasn't my son is affected by this
it's Melania the not even Alanya the
first lady has a son and that's why she
cares about this Melania by the way
didn't even react in the sense that for
her she seems totally acquainted with
Donald Trump's complete lack of interest
in Baron Trump and speaking of kids if
she or he care about kids so much
they've pulled flu vaccines from the
border camps he's lent credence to anti
vaccine ideas that are extremely
dangerous to children he bullies people
on Twitter while his wife claims that
she's trying to work on stopping
bullying if having a kid makes her care
so much about children
there's plenty more that she could be
encouraging Donald Trump to do and
really take that seriously some of the
strangest video that I have seen of
Donald Trump very very bizarre
curious what you think about it